[Music]
foreign
the 9 pm Prime Time news in Port Sudan
goes on air this little Studio has
replaced Sudan's State tv headquarters
in cartoon now occupied by rapid support
forces militia
the mutinous forces attacked all media
facilities including the national TV so
we found it necessary to relaunch the
national TV broadcaster on the federal
level which we managed to achieve from
here in just a few days
the all of Sudan's major federal
institutions followed suit by moving
their operations to the sport city of
less than a million inhabitants the
federal cabinet and its relocated
ministers held their first meeting on
Wednesday since fighting began three
months ago only one member of the ruling
sovereignty Council showed up here and
had a brief discussion with the
ministers before the session but he
didn't want his name or picture to be
made public probably an indication of
how tense a security situation is even
here far away from cartoon
the Old Town District dates back more
than a hundred years that's how long
Port Sudan has been serving as the
country's economic capital it accounts
for 90 percent of Sudan's International
Trade thanks to its strategic position
on the Red Sea
it's also a fishing town and a tourist
destination for scuba divers and coral
reef lovers
most humanitarian aid for war victims
first arrives here by air and sea
students and others from all over Sudan
come for school certificates and all
types of official documentation
a new Factory for the printing of
passports is being built the Central
Bank resumes its services here after the
shutdown of its main headquarters in
Khartoum the city's administrative
district is a closed military zone
filming is restricted and few officials
agree to talk to the media
the region has seen rebellions in the
past and the recent call to join the
Army is elitmus test of loyalty with all
of that and thousands is keeping the
fighting and awaiting evacuation or
humanitarian support Sudan's leaders
have their hands full Muhammad
al-jazeera Paul Sudan